Why good morning you sexy beast. Would you
like me to make you some breakfast? Oh,
I'm sorry. I was having flashback
there folks. This is Tim Ferris.
This is an addendum,
an urgent update recorded after this
episode is completed because I was going
through a roster of all
of the most amazing things
I've been able to experience
in my life and at the top of the
list was floating at zero gravity,
experiencing weightlessness in a shuttle
and being able to say chase after
globules of water floating in midair or
chase skittles that you've tossed into
the air.
It's floating right in front of your face,
say five feet away or scurrying around
all the way around the perimeter of the
shuttle, like a hamster in a hamster
wheel if you were inverted. In a way,
it's really amazing and I loved it so
much that I decided to give away a flight.
So I am giving away a flight at
zero gravity and you can get it.
There's no cost involved,
but it's only possible this week.
That is the week of Monday,
April 20th so jump on this right now.
I would suggest that you
pause this and check it out.
Just go to four hour workweek.com forward
slash zero that's four hour workweek,
all spelled out, Fou, r, h, o, u,
r, et Cetera, forward slash zero z.
E. R. O. Let's check it out and now
back to your regular programming.
This episode is brought to
you by listen headphones,
which are gorgeous and produce
incredible, incredible, incredible.
At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living.
This episode is brought to you
by listen headphones. Listen,
headphones are gorgeous,
made out of real exotic reclaimed wood,
but they are also doing good in the world.
He proceeds from each purchase.
Help someone to hear for the first time
through the Starkey hearing foundation.
I've been using listen
headphones since they came out,
partially because the founders started
the company after reading the four hour
workweek and now they're available
in Nordstrom and all over the place.
They're super high quality and if you
want to see the headphones that I traveled
with that I love both
any or an out of ear,
so kind of big Ole old school headphones,
then you can go listen.
headphones.com forward slash Tim that's
LSTM headphones.com forward slash Tim
you will also get a $50 that's right,
$50 discount. That's a big weapon.
Five zero folks,
so go to listen to headphones.com
forward slash Tim Lstm,
headphones.com forward slash.
Tim
this episode is brought
to you by 99 designs,
which is your one stop shop for
all things graphic design related.
They have thousands upon thousands
of designers around the world.
You put up what you want, whether
that's a card, a tee shirt,
a website and APP thumbnail,
whatever, and they submit drafts,
mockups and designs that you can choose
from and you get an original design you
love or your money back.
I've used them for years including to
grab cover concepts for the four hour
body, which went on to become number
one New York times and it really was a
springboard for everything.
So go to 99 designs.com forward slash
Tim and you can also get two things,
a $99 upgrade and just for the
month of April, just for you guys,
you can get an additional $30 off and
that is total savings of one 29 so check
out 99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
Hello Ladies and gentlemen,
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
I am drinking tea with coconut
oil in it because I am in Ketosis.
So my brain is running like speedy
Gonzales on some type of biochemical
advantage, but that's not
what I'm here to talk about.
I am here to do what I do every episode
and that is deconstruct world class
performers to find the tools,
tricks, routines, habits,
and so on that you can use whether
those people are billionaire investors.
Like for instance Peter Teal,
who was the first money into Facebook,
also co founder of paypal and Palentier
or celebrities and actors like Arnold
Schwarzenegger,
uh,
tech icons like Matt Mullenweg behind
a wordpress and wordpress.com and so on
and so forth.
Musicians,
we've got everybody and I have wanted to
interview a professional wrestler for a
very long time now after seeing the movie,
the wrestler,
but also having wrestled myself and uh,
having watched WWE and WWF
f before that and then the,
the rise of MMA and I managed
to get ahold of a fantastic,
fantastic performer and
incredible athlete, triple h.
So triple h who is a 13 time
world champion in the WWE,
but that is not all.
He's also the executive vice president
of talent live events and creative at the
WWE. And we talk about just
about everything in this episode.
His real name is Paul Levesque and we
dig into the questions of misconceptions
related to both triple h,
his, uh, his stage name,
his stage persona and WWE the important
lessons he learned while training with a
wrestler named killer Kuwalski,
including getting hit in the back of the
head with a phone book in a garbage bag.
Ouch. Uh, and, uh, we
get into his longevity,
how he avoids and also repairs injuries,
pregame rituals,
including input from a
trainer named Joe to Franco.
Of course his colleague and arms.
The undertaker and even Floyd Mayweather.
And who does he model? Uh,
how does he view parenting?
He has a bunch of daughters, uh, and uh,
it goes on and on. We really dig deep.
It's a turned out
better than I could have expected
and I expected it to be good.
So I hope you really enjoy this.
Of course I'll show notes.
Can Be found a four hour workweek.com
forward slash podcast all spelled out and
please enjoy my conversation with the
one and only triple h Paul Levesque.
Paul, welcome to the show. Thank you
very much medicine honor to be here.
I am so excited for this.
You are a massive human being.
It makes your job requirement then.
It does seem to be a job
requirement and the eye,
you have worn a lot of hats and
I've had a lot of different titles,
a lot of different jobs.
When someone asks you what do you
do if they don't recognize you,
how do you answer that question?
Oh God, it's funny now
because I'm kind of in that,
this weird kind of Combo twilight
zone of the last bits of my,
my in ring wrestling career, you know? Um,
even then when I did it then I used to
say I was an entertainer and because if
people are the WWE is a weird thing,
like one of those things, like
if you, if you're not into it,
no explanation can explain it to you to
make you like it and then you are into
it. There's no explanation necessary, you
know, it, it just is what it is. And, um,
so to say, sometimes it, oh,
WWE, like it would go like,
oh, look at the rest of them,
you know? And it just had
a weird connotation to it.
When you say entertainer, oh,
what kind of, Oh, you know, WWE, it just
took on a different meaning. Sure. Uh,
to people that don't understand what
we do. Um, so I was went with that.
Right now it's, um, it's
kind of a combo. You know,
we have a saying that we use that WWE,
which is our job is to put
smiles on people's faces
and it's kind of the overall
thing of what we do.
But I spend 90% of my day as an executive.
So there you go.
Okay.
We're going to also,
we're going to dig into that and rewind
the clock and look at the trajectory,
but what are misconceptions
that people have about you or
triple h or at WWT? Um, I
think they don't, you know,
they just see what they see
on TV. They see, you know, um,
okay.
The, the misconception for me is
that I'm very much what you see on,
on television or him that
I'm this character or they
see the simplistic things
of what we do. You know, it's funny, even
if you have this huge fan of the WWE,
they get so upset over
things like, um, well good.
Why would this guy be that guy? Just Co,
you know, it's one of the terms right now.
It's buried them, you know,
it's, um, it's a show.
And what they don't get about our
show is we are like this never ending.
If you can compare it to whatever you
want, comic books, soap, opera, TV,
drama, movie, but it never ends.
There's always another chapter.
And they get so upset in the moment
of not knowing that, you know,
not liking maybe the end of
the chapter that they're on,
there's another chapter
to search tomorrow.
It actually started right now
when this one ended, you know,
and they don't get that and they can't
wait for that and they don't understand
all the complexities that goes
on, you know, go on behind
the scenes. So it's that,
that's probably the biggest misconception
is that we're just, you know, the,
that the WWE is just a bunch of guys,
um,
at its simplest form that just go to the
ring in their underwear and pretend to
fight with each other, you know? Um,
but when you really break it down,
it's a massive global business.
Oh, there's a lot behind it. Oh my God.
I've been so impressed by it for so,
so long.
Not The least of which,
and we'll certainly explore the,
the physical and mental stamina.
How many matches would
you say you have had
total to date? Televised or
otherwise? Thousands, you know, if,
if you break it down simplistically
in math is not my strong suit. So,
but you know, I started
wrestling I think in like 93 ish,
just just training.
92 93 training.
And was this in New Hampshire or was
this in New Hampshire? I went to, um,
I trained with a guy named [inaudible]
wall ski and old who my Mama loves by the
way. Oh really? Yeah. I wanted to dig
into that. Yeah, he was, uh, you know,
one of the first guys to become kind
of like globally known and I started
training with a Meta camp, a
school, if you want to call it that.
It was like a little rundown mill
building with a boxing ring in it and a in
Malden, Massachusetts. And I
started training under there.
So if you break it down from there to
today of 20 plus years and then when you
know,
once I made it to the WWE,
which was 95 even if you just want to
look at it from there and just say 20
years,
20 years,
I probably for a lot of those
years wrestled 250 280 days a year.
Sometimes on the weekends
we did double shots,
so we'd wrestle a matinee in the afternoon
and then a night show. So it's a lot.
A lot of mileage. Yeah,
it's a lot of mileage. Yeah.
What were the most thing we always
said, it's not the years, it's the miles
it both figuratively and literally
and it's a hell of a lot of travel.
But before I get to asking you about
travel and all of these different training
aspects,
what were the most important lessons you
learned while training with killer call
scheme?
It's funny.
A lot of the things I think as in
life he taught me a lot of things.
Um, that I didn't know he
was teaching me at the time.
He would tell me a lot of things
that I would be like, ah, he's,
he's just like the Mr
Miyagi approach. Yeah, yeah.
It was a very, it would have worked
very well in today's millennial age,
but like he had that his
theory of telling you,
you did something wrong was hitting you
in the back of the head with a phone
book that was in like a shopping
bag, you know? And, um, but yeah,
he,
he would just teach all the,
he wouldn't say a whole lot and then all
of a sudden he'd come in and he would
say, um, you know, it needs to,
you need to be spectacular. Make
everybody look at you, no one else.
And then he would just walk away
and then you'd be like, well,
what does that mean? Like, I
don't, you know what I mean?
You kind of had to figure it out.
Now there's a lot of things that he said
to me then that I find myself telling
the young guys now in a different way.
Um,
but it's the same lessons
kind of, you know? Um,
are there any examples that
come to mind? Well, just,
just in how to be spectacular,
but also out of to break things down into,
to just look at what you do.
Like never be,
never be satisfied with what you do.
If you don't do something well don't do
it unless you want to spend the time to
improve that.
Like it's still to this day,
I see a lot of guys do stuff in the ring
that I'm like, hm. He doesn't do that.
Well he does it all the time. It's
just, you know, you shouldn't do that.
I have things that I don't do
well in the ring. Just don't know.
It's just what would
be, oh man. For example,
there's this one thing that
guys take where they, they um,
they go through the top and middle
turnbuckle and hit the post right from the
inside and uh, hit it with
their shoulder. I just,
it's one of those mental block
things for me. Like I can't,
I just can't seem to navigate
going between the two
turnbuckles and getting the
thing.
Like I always get stuck somehow or ab
tried to do it before and it's just one of
those things like it doesn't work
out well for me, so I never do it.
And if guys will grab me in the
ring over the years and say like,
take the post and I'll just,
no, no. You know what I mean?
Cause I don't midflight correction,
I just don't do that.
Well I'm not going to do it.
And I think there's little things like
that that guys don't analyze what they do,
they do what they do and then
they go and they say, oh,
that was really good in the
overall picture of things.
Right. It was really good.
People really liked it.
It was,
but there were some things in there
that weren't really good. So the,
it averaged out well, but there are
things they should have admitted. Yeah.
You know, and to me, I don't
know, I've always been the
kind of guy, if, if you're,
if you're doing it, why, why
wasn't everything, which you
wanted it to be in there,
there shouldn't be wasted movement.
There shouldn't be things that
aren't what you want them to be.
I don't want to do something just to get
to the next thing, you know? No, I do.
And what are you particularly good at
in the, in that, in that environment,
what are the things that you,
the strengths that you focused on?
For me it was never about,
um,
he was never about individual moves.
And I think as the business,
maybe some guys now look at that and they,
they think differently because they
might look at my style and say, look,
I was never over the top spectacular guy,
but I wasn't supposed to be.
I was usually the bad guy.
So I wanted to have that.
I want it to be that constant and let
the other guy be spectacular around me.
And it, for me, it was never
about the spectacular moves.
It was about the drama of the,
the match.
And I look at what we do is,
um,
we're, we're more like rocky the
movie, then we are legitimate,
you know, like boxing, right? It's
about the story that you tell.
So if the story is really good going in
and you care about the two characters,
and then you make that emotional story
play out through those two characters,
non-verbally in the ring,
that's the magic of what we do.
It doesn't matter if, you know, um,
yeah, it makes the highlight reel like,
oh my God, he did this one spectacular
move was crazy. I don't know how he,
he made it through that or whatever.
It's not really about that because
tomorrow there'll be,
I get another guy can do that move better
than you just did it and it will be
even more spectacular.
He'll come up with another way to do it.
That's even crazier.
Well, you mentioned rocky, right? It's,
it's, it's a, it's about the story arc,
not just a handful of really
good lines of dialogue.
Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. And, and that's
the thing of it. And you'll watch,
it's one of the things that works.
We have the WWE network.
It's a lot of old content.
People will go back and they'll
watch wrestlemania one, you know, um,
over and over again and
how great it is and,
or wrestlemania three and all these
things is because it's an emotional story.
If it was just about the
moves, it wouldn't be so
impactful to you still it the,
the emotional story of why people will
go back and watch the movie rocky over
and over again because it's a great story.
Um,
they very rarely go back and watch now
there's exceptions, Muhammad Ali and,
and for men or something, you
know, um, moments in time,
but the average person,
unless they're like a boxing connoisseur,
doesn't go back and watch
boxing over and over again.
No. And you know, it's fascinating about
the examples you just gave, like a,
whether it's Ali Frazier or whatever,
those,
those in real life ended up being like
story arcs because you would have this
back and forth in this drama
and the Thrilla in Manila.
And there were all the elements of
sort of the, the monomyth or the, yeah.
Well, and even when you go back
and usually watch those fights,
you go back and you watch them in a show
that now chronicles the story of the
ties them together. Yeah, yeah.
It chronicles the story of those,
those epic contests, you know, and that's
the reality of the story. You know, it's,
um, you know, said all the time, if
you know who's in the ring fighting,
you'll tune in and your watch to just
watch two guys fight for no apparent
reason. It's not that interesting
unless you're a connoisseur of the,
of what they're doing.
You know,
if you're watching the UFC and you're a
big mixed martial arts fan or all those
things, and there's a lot of
those, but they're very into the,
what's going on scientifically
and you know, the, the chess game,
the technical chess game that's going on.
But that's not the general
public to hit the general public.
They need to know something about the
two guys and why they're fighting.
You know,
the, uh, the fighting
at your peak point in,
in your,
your onstage wrestling career,
he mentioned 200 and something
like 250 to 300 days of the year.
You're probably traveling something
like that and traveling. Yeah. And uh,
what were some of the keys to your
longevity being able to maintain that?
And I know we have a common connection
and Joe to Franco and he's mentioned that
you very,
very rarely if ever miss training days
and then maybe you could speak to that,
but even if that means coming in at
two to three in the morning to train,
what are,
what have been some of the keys are
practices that have allowed you to sustain
that type of torturous schedule?
Um,
I think you know, you,
you speak a lot in your,
in your podcast, in, in,
in your books and everything about
routines and having things that you do.
And I'm very big in that way.
And I like,
I like to have my life
kind of like when it,
when it gets chaotic
and bothers me and it's,
which sounds silly because like
what we do is chaotic at all times.
Like my day varies and you know,
people talk about when you do live TV,
like Monday night raw for us,
we work on that show and edited and done
and sometimes you guys are walking up
the curtain and somebody shouting a
change to them as they're walking through
the curtain. You know, it's,
it's, so the chaos is there,
but having that consistent thing.
So for me,
I had very distinct things.
Like if I was in the beginning there
wasn't as much supplements and there is a
little bit more difficult,
but as supplements became more available,
I would,
I'm like big on the preparation part.
So like if I was going to get on a
plane to fly to Japan, I would take,
um, either containers or, or
later when they were there, the,
I would make my own protein shakes.
Right.
I'd put the two scoops of protein and
the thing, I'd put some oil in there,
I'd whatever I needed, I'd put
the top on it, no liquid in there,
and I'd stick it inside my carry on
bag so, and I would time it in my head.
So I'm on the flight for, it's a 16
hour flight. I've gotten three hours.
I need to eat every three hours. I'm not
going to count on the food on the plane.
That will just be bonus food.
So every three hours I have a shake for
every three hours and then set my watch
to go off every three hours, time to
eat, and I'd get a shake out, get water,
drink my shake, put it in and go back to
sleep. Right. Whatever I needed to do.
When I landed, I would check into
the hotel. Second we checked in,
I'd ask them to the gym open,
can I go train?
Even if it was to get on a
bike and ride for 15 minutes,
reset that I learned early that it seemed
to me anytime I did that I didn't get
jet lag. Anytime I did that,
I seem to like we can kit,
we use wrestling terms like I've
got to kick out faster, right?
So while everybody else would be
in the building dragon that day,
I'd be like feminine. I feel great.
You know, I don't feel so bad.
I'm getting your blood flowing,
resetting your clock. Um, you know,
if we were in Australia,
I would always like that last day there
I would force myself to stay up because
then I could sleep the whole way home.
And by the time I landed I was landing
in the morning and it's perfect.
Like I'm just waking up and it's great.
You want to do the same thing Atlanta,
try to find a gym, whether it hotel
something, ride a bike, you set my clock,
do the deal, you know? Um,
so those routines and regimented
stuff and same with my training.
Um,
when new guys would start a lot.
I'm on the road like internationally
when we're all traveling together.
It's hard when you go overseas,
you're on a bus there,
there's a gym set up for you,
but they don't know how,
like how do I get to the gym? I'm not
sure. Am I supposed to go downstairs,
get on a bus? I don't know. The guys
would always come to me and say,
hey look, we've always heard that you go
to the gym every day. Can I go with you?
So yeah, I'd meet downstairs,
bunch of guys who come down,
we'd all go to the gym together
cause I would go every day.
I didn't like missing it.
I didn't like, you know,
it was to me was that regimented thing
and I can look back at my career and say,
I think part of that regimented stuff
is why I was able to maintain it or,
or maintain that schedule because I
was one of the guides also that really,
truly believed in that when you make it,
the job gets harder.
It's not the other way around. You
don't make it and then go, okay,
now I can cruise because now I'm the guy.
And now that means I can say no,
and I can not do these things. I felt
the opposite. When you get there,
now it's your responsibility
to not say no. So, you know, I,
I've had times where I've worked 64
straight days and just everybody else went
home. I went on a media tour,
everybody else went back home.
I went to something else. I did
that for years, you know, and,
and that, um, that regimented,
having those distinct
patterns so to speak,
um,
I think helped help keep that.
I think it helps preserve your bandwidth
also for making decisions about other
things.
So you don't have to decide each morning
or each day what all the elements that
your teen are going to look like.
A, it's funny, I heard you talk, uh,
it just recently,
I listen to podcasts and my research
for this because I've read your books,
but you're hearing somebody
speak is different than
what you put in your mind of
how they speak. Right? So
I want to feel like, God,
that guy sounds a hot dumber on audio,
but you know,
you put something if you had
to then get there and go vote.
It's not what I expected at all.
So I listened to it.
Yes. Um, you, um, you spoke, uh,
and I forgot what I was
talking about. That was bad
interview etiquette on my, no,
no, no. Yeah, we were talking
about routines. It's bad memory on
routine. Oh, I know what I was going
to say. Yeah. I believe that um,
like training is almost like a
meditation. Right? I totally agree.
The Anthony Robbins say he didn't, didn't
meditate cause you like shutting off.
He's the opposite.
He wants to just keep going.
But I also believe you need to reboot
your brain because your brain will get
stuck in like,
it's like when you go to sleep and you
can't stop thinking about something you
got going on at work and
you can't get it out.
And in the morning you realize that it
was actually jibberish that was in your
brain going on.
Um,
I think training when you do it well,
if you're into it,
like you can't focus,
you can't be in the middle of trying
to do a heavy set of something and be
thinking about another project.
You have to be in that moment
and it allows you to reboot,
which I kind of believe is what
meditation and all that stuff is. Anyways.
It's just a reset button for a second
that just allows you to go like, okay,
start over, clean the plate and
knowledge, do this again. You know?
And that's really to me what training is.
Definitely
digging a little bit more on the
routines. For instance, on in the last,
let's just say as you've gotten older in
the last handful of years, how do you,
what is your pregame ritual if you have
one before you're going to go out and
compete and perform?
Yeah, that's all that. But it
just became this as the of, uh,
of age of I never, and just for people
listening, if you don't mind me asking,
how old are you at the
45? But, so, you know,
for years when I was doing all that
stuff with wrestling, you know,
wrestling all those dates and everything.
Um,
it's funny because some of the younger
guys would, would joke with me about it.
Like you're like the old school guy.
Like I would literally be
sitting in a chair up at,
we call it gorilla position right
before you walk out the curtain, uh,
named after an old wrestler,
grill monsoon. But um,
I would just be sitting in
a chair. My music, it is,
I'd get up and go to the ring and say,
you don't warm up at all.
So I'll walk to the ring as good to get a
good warm up. You know, I'll start slow,
it'll be fine.
Now I have to like stretch and warm up.
And Joe Franco,
you mentioned my strength
and conditioning guys.
One of the things when I'm
really bad with years and dates,
but the four years ago was my career
was kind of winding down and I was,
but I was, I was still wrestling fairly
regularly and I had had this problem,
I thought it was a neck
injury and a really having
all this problem with my neck
and my shoulder. And I, I um,
I got a new position with a company where
I needed to go make a couple of movies
for them. Long story, but I
went to go make two movies.
I ended up taking about a month off from
the ring to go make these two movies
and then was supposed to come back
while I was making the movies.
One day I went to the gym to train and um,
it had gotten to a point where I couldn't
raise my left arm up over my shoulder
and my neck was really bad and I'd
been going to see our team physician,
you know, the guy that runs our
medical. And I'd been, you know,
getting stuck with needles and die and
Mris and things and they kept saying like,
it looks great. We don't see this
clearly something nerve going on here,
but we don't know what it is.
And they kept doing all this stuff and
when the gym one day and tore my bicep
and it didn't hurt at all, it likes snap.
I looked down, I have the big gap in my
arm. I was just mad more than anything.
I was like, Oh, you just rolled up
like a Venetian blind toward the top.
So just talk down and made like this
divot there. Right. And I heard,
I had headphones on, I heard it
and I looked down and it was just
David, I was like, son of a bitch,
I can't believe you tore my bicep.
So I'm like mad. I put my weights down
and like literally I was done training.
It was just going to do like a couple
of extra sets of Bicep to wherever and,
and uh,
I called the guy to come back and get me.
And as I went to go outside,
like I was sweating and out and piss off,
just going to leave and I go to
put my sweatshirt on. And as I did,
I put my sweatshirt,
like through my arm up over my head to
put my sweatshirt on and realize it,
wait a minute,
I can move my,
my arm all the way
around my head like that.
I couldn't do their shoulder
mobility. Yeah. I was like,
everything came back and hey,
wait my neck,
it doesn't hurt.
It was all from like this a bicep.
And um, I had to get surgery
and the whole thing and it,
but it got me to a point in my head like,
I'm getting older,
I'm falling apart a little bit.
Like I have to start,
maybe I should think about trying to
train like an athlete instead of just like
going to the gym, being a bodybuilder
and just looking good or whatever.
So I'm not like a guy that just like to
call the local gym, like I have to them,
like dig into it.
So I started like researching
trainers and everything and um,
okay.
Ironically,
I ended up probably where you did in your
quest to do when you did for our body,
which is you start researching all these
guys that become the best at what they
do. And I, I come across Joe de Franco,
it keeps coming back up. Joda Franco.
So then I called Joe to Franco out of the
blue one day and just say, um, you know,
hey, I was, I was actually,
because he was in Jersey and I was in
Connecticut and I was thinking maybe he
could recommend me to somebody. And uh,
he said, can I come and meet with you?
I'd like to meet with you.
And just so I can analyze thing.
I still had my arm in a
sling and everything had just
finished making the movies.
I didn't have the surgery until after
I finish making the movies. And um,
he came and said, uh, after we met, he's
like, you seem like a really great guy.
I like to take a stab at doing
this with you. I'll drive up here,
I'm willing to do it, drive up. And
uh, there's the thing, he's awesome.
He's a great guy. And for people
who aren't familiar, uh, he's,
he's very well known for a lot of reasons,
but it does a lot of work with, uh,
football athletes training for
the NFL combine. Yeah. And, uh,
that's how he ended up that the
chapters in the four hour body where I,
I showed how unathletic I am. Uh, but how
much Joe could improve my performance,
attempting to simulate the combine for,
for a handful of chapters.
But please continue. I just want
to give some context for you. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Great Guy. Yeah.
And I'm just wealth of knowledge,
incredibly smart.
And um, he said to me, um,
so this will be a difficult transition
for you because your mindset is totally
different. You know, I'd never been
with a strength and conditioning guy.
Everything I learned in the gym was from
bodybuilders were power lifters. I just,
I just went to the gym and trained with
guys and learned everything I could,
but I was a sponge, you know,
Arnold was my hero and you know,
I'd like just was a sponge for all that
stuff. But that's how I learned it.
So strength and conditioning and the
whole stretching and mobility was totally
foreign to me. And he said, uh, this
is going to be a tough thing for you.
We'll see if you can do it. Cause
tough with old dogs, new tricks.
And I just want him. And I said,
dude, I will tell you this. I am,
I'm all in. Tell me what to do. I'll
go do it. But it changed my life,
changed my life athletically. I
went from a guy with, you know,
gimping going upstairs because
my knees were killing me.
I've torn both of my quads and my
knees were really bad and all that.
I had zero knee pain now as
strong as they've ever been.
I don't have physical issues,
but it's because of that type of training.
And Joe and um, you know, he
was one of the guys that got me.
Like when you do wrestle,
here's what we're going to do.
We're going to get you in this kind
of shape and then you're going to,
he's going to be your pre match ritual of,
you know,
you're stretching in your mobility.
We're going to light your body up,
get your nerves kicking in and firing, and
then you're going to go, you know, and,
um, that's what I do now and it
works out a whole lot better.
Well, what are, what are,
as opposed to going from the gorilla
position straight out to the, to the ring,
what are a, and I can prep what
I'll provide for folks. Uh,
obviously lots of links to
everything that you're up to,
but also I'll pin gel and get some links
to exercises and some videos. What,
what does that look like now? What are
some of the exercises or the sequence?
It's, um, it's a lot of mobility
stuff. Kasik squats. Um,
you know, um, is that a weighted
caustic squatters? Oh, no,
he'll, well, it's depends,
but usually I don't like if I'm
getting ready to go for a match,
but like he'll have me do
caustic squats into, um,
maybe just like a, uh, a squat.
But when I come down and pushing my knees
out to decide to stretch my groin out
into some type of like, um, uh,
he centric explosive pushup.
But just getting things to fire my
nervous system, wake my nervous system up,
but then also just open my joints up
a little bit and just warm my body up.
But it's never anything like I see guys
running down hallways and doing all
these things to get a sweat going. I'm
never at that point. But when I'm done it,
I always feel like alive,
you know,
as opposed to just kind
of physically shutdown,
but mentally aware because I'm about
to go to the ring. So you know,
no matter how many years
you've been doing this,
you still like nervous and
like freaking out and um,
to, to then have your body
just kick in and wake up,
boom when you're there. You know what
I mean? And that's really what it is.
But it's, it's just the, he varies it,
but it's a little series of exercises.
It just makes me go,
how long does it typically take? Five,
10 minutes. Not Short and sweet. Yeah.
It's not the, I just go white
right from one thing to the other.
Awesome. Good little
deal. Yeah. I'll Ping Joe.
So people you can find that at the
show notes at a four hour blog com. Uh,
the fear factor,
what you guys do is it
can be very dangerous.
I mean there are risks
involved when you're,
when you're nervous or have been nervous.
Uh,
what is your inner dialogue sound like
when you're preparing yourself to go out,
when you've been most nervous?
What are you saying to yourself?
Um,
so it's changed over the years.
I used to get really intense and really
like almost like I'm that same level of
intensity.
If you are going to go for a personal
record squat or something where you know,
you just get in that zone of intensity
and just nothing else is around you in
your, in your own little world and just
on fire ready to tear through this thing.
And that when I was younger,
that used to be the thing for me.
Now it's much more of an inner dialogue
of you had been doing this for 20 years,
you know how to do this.
Like relax and this is fun.
Like, and in some way there's
that inner dialogue and me saying,
could be the last time you do this,
enjoy it. You know what I mean? Like,
um, uh, an undertaker and I
had a conversation a couple
of years ago about this,
like, you, you, it's, it's a little
bit of like, you can still do this,
like in calming yourself down, but
at the same point in time, like,
don't forget to enjoy this moment,
like when you're out there,
because you might not get another one.
You don't know. You know, and, and,
and injuries do happen,
especially as you get older. So,
and you can't think about it once you're
out there. And that's the thing for me,
it's always been this emotion and nerve
and the s my music hits and the second I
walk out, it's gone. Like,
I don't have any of it when I'm in
the ring waiting for the other guy or
whatever. I don't have any of it. Um,
and it's an interesting thing to me that,
um,
I'm friends with Floyd Mayweather
and incredible athlete. Yeah.
And I was walking him to
the ring one time and, uh,
I think we fought Marquez and,
um,
we have the early in the guys came and
got me and I wanted to watch some of the
undercard and then they came and got
me and they said, you know, Florida,
just want to say hi before he
starts getting ready and stuff.
Chat with me for a few
minutes. So I came, we,
Steph and I went backstage
with my wife and, um,
we in his locker room and he's laying
down on the couch watching basketball game
and we come in and say hello and all that.
And he's a guy I haven't seen,
you know,
now we're talking a little bit,
but I'm trying to be ultra respectful
of him. He's about to go in, you know,
massive fight. And so I, uh, the second,
there's like a lull in the conversation.
I'm like,
all right man,
well we're going to get out of your hair
and head back in and we'll come back
here when it's time for us to get ready
for your deal. And he's like, man,
you don't gotta take off. She
could sit down and we're, I'm,
I'm enjoying the conversation. Have
funny. And he's like completely relaxed.
And I said, so another low
in the conversation, I go,
we're going to run flood. I,
I don't want to be in your way.
And he goes,
honor,
I'm telling you I'm not. I'm just
chilling, watching the game. And I said,
you're not wound up about this at all.
And he goes,
why would I be wound up?
I'm either ready or I'm not worrying
bottle right now. I get to
change a damn thing. Right?
It was going to happen. It's
going to happen here. Right.
So I've either done everything I
can to be ready for this or I'm not.
It's a fair point. I sat back down, we
watch a game. You're like, all right,
I want to be here. Right? Yeah.
Just as very calm and relaxed.
And I think when you feel in
your mind that you're ready,
you're ready and you're going
to have those nerves, but
it's, you know, it's there.
When you were coming up,
let's just say when you,
when you would hit your stride
somewhat. So you're starting to, uh,
make the ascent through the
ranks and really become popular.
When you thought of the word successful,
who was the person in
your head at that time?
MMM,
I don't know.
It's hard to say because I looked at an
inside of the inside of our business.
There were guys like for me, um, you know,
my favorite performer
character was ric flair. Um,
just kind of felt like overall he had
the best package of everything to offer.
You know, there were guys that
were great showman, very popular,
or guys that were great
at one thing or Bobby,
he had the kind of the Combo
of great in ring performer.
It made everybody look good,
does great character, all,
all these things inside
the wrestling business.
That was a component of success for me.
Um,
just that level of performer,
the way he handled himself in the ring.
I always want it to be the in ring kind
of general and understand. And I just,
one of the things I prided myself
on at the peak of my career was
mmm.
I could tell you at any
given time if there was six
people involved in something,
I can tell you at any given time,
if I close my eyes in the ring where they
all were like no matter how much they
were moving around and what they
were doing, I knew where they were.
I knew what they had in their hands.
I knew like just on glimpses as
I was moving around the ring,
I always felt like it was my job.
If something was going to screw up,
that was my fault. It wasn't because
he didn't know what was coming.
It was because I didn't control that.
Um,
so I was felling to control was mine to
take because it was what I could count
on. I couldn't rely on, you know,
this might get screwed up because maybe
there's a confusion between those two
guys over there.
It's supposed to do their thing.
So I always took it on me to make sure
I was there to tell them this is coming
up, be ready, here we go, get the
chair, whatever. You know, um,
flare was very good at that.
So that was like, for me,
from that point of view was
a success, um, component.
But there was a lot of
things that I looked for.
Wrestling didn't define me as
far as what I saw was successful.
I looked at and um, you know, I
looked at my, and one now Vince,
I looked at that is a guy that
saw business that was one thing,
but had a vision of it
being something else.
He saw this little territory business
and thought they should be one global
brand that everybody watches
because the world's getting smaller.
Cable is taking over.
And so he had this vision and then
he just kind of set out doing it.
I looked at Arnold,
I remember as a kid reading education
of a bodybuilder and very structured,
methodical set of here's
what I want to do.
Here's what I want to be and here's
how I'm going to get there. You know,
that those kind of things in those kind
of people were success models for me.
Arnold.
Um,
was that in the structure?
You know,
I just said it to him a few weeks ago.
Like for me,
I say this in interviews a lot.
The Jim taught me everything I
need to know for life. You know,
I walked into Jim at 14,
I fell in love with it.
I fell in love with the end result.
Look right as always in awe of these big,
powerful, impressive guys. I think it's
part of what I dug about wrestling.
You know,
I enjoyed the physical and all that
stuff of it and fell in love with that
really holy, that's probably what
led me to the gym at first. But,
but just the discipline of
it and the going to the gym.
And when I say it's like life, the more
you put it in, the more you get out,
the harder you work, the
better the results, you know,
if you're willing to prepare to sacrifice.
It touches about going to the gym,
lifting weights, and then going out
and goofing off. The rest of the time,
it's your life.
So if you discipline your diet,
if you discipline your rest, if you
don't go to the party with your friends,
if you don't do all these things,
your results follow suit. Um,
you know, I, I just did, um,
I just got inducted into the
international sports hall of fame.
Arnold's international sports,
all friends.
But I bring it up because
Evander Holyfield was there
and he told his story and
I never heard it said this way
before and I'm sorry of Andrew,
but I'm going to steal this.
Um, he told me that, you know,
he was giving his speech and he said
that his coach at one point in time told
them very, very first day, he
said, you could be Muhammad Ali,
you could be the next Muhammad
Ali. And uh, he said, do
you want to do that? And he,
he said he had to ask his mom and then
he went back home and he came back and he
said, I want to do that. And he said,
okay, is that a dream or a goal?
This is a difference.
I'd never heard it said that way before,
but it struck to me so much so
that I've said it to my kid now.
Is that a dream or goal cause a dream to
something you fantasize about that just
will never happen?
Probably the goal is something you set
a plan and work towards and achieve and
set a dream or goal.
Um,
kind of always looked
at my stuff that way.
So the people that were successful models
to me were people that had structured
goals and then put a plan in
place to get to those things.
And I think that's what
impressed me about Arnold.
You weren't impressed me about
my father in law to this day.
He's still very much a,
you know, here's the goal,
here's how I'm going to get there.
Energizer bunny. That's amazing. Yeah.
You guys seem like peas in a pod from us.
Stamina and endurance.
Stamina.
And do you, I've heard you say it before
when when you have that goal in mind,
now it's not, I got to do this
thing to get that done. It's,
you can't wait to do that thing to get
that done because it's going to get you
closer to your goal.
Right.
Well,
since the compass that allows you
to find order in the chaos to the,
uh, parenting. I don't, I don't yet
have kids now that I know of. Uh,
at some point I would
love to have a family.
How do you think about being a father?
What type of father do you want to be?
What do you think is, is
important in that, in that role?
That's a tough one. I have three
girls. Three, uh, I have, uh, an eight,
six and four. Very well spaced. Yeah.
And that's it. We're done.
Yeah. But, um, it's, man, it's,
it's hard when the pressure
as a parent, if you, you know,
hopefully if everybody takes the
job seriously, you know this,
you're giving them the examples of
how they're going to live their life.
Kids don't do what you say.
They do what they see. Um,
so how you live your life. Is there an
example? You know, I've heard it said,
and I believe this is like the way I treat
their mother and the way I treat them
is what they're going to look for in a,
in a significant other.
Um, well you got to think,
oh yeah, like so what are,
what do I want them to have in their life?
Holy cow and I got to do all
that stuff. It's a lot, you know,
and then you add in all the other
things of life. It's a very,
it's a very difficult challenge.
Um, but you, you want to,
you want to teach them right from wrong.
You want to teach them,
you want to give them a path and a
direction. But also same point in time,
you know, you learn as much from you
failures as you do from your successes.
So you can't,
you can't give them everything that
you want to help them. Ouzo bad.
Like I'm watching you make a
mistake and I want to help you,
but go ahead and make the mistake because
you got to learn from that mistake.
You know what I mean? Um,
and it's, it's tough to do,
but you have to and there's no manual.
That's the hard thing about kids, right?
There's no manual that comes with and
you're just doing the best you can.
I remember when we got our first
one home, we, the boss battle,
they put it in the car seat and you'd
take the thing home and then we walked in
the door and we put it on the step
and we were like, what do we do now?
We just stood there looking at her for
a little bit like what, what do we like?
What do we do? Like eventually it, she
cried and he had a feeder and whatever.
You don't know what to do.
We have a kid only cap.
Yeah. Luckily I was a,
I've got to go on the road.
The aspect of routines that we
touched on earlier, I'd love to, to,
to bring back into focus for a second,
uh,
specifically morning
routines. What is, what,
what does the first 60
minutes of your day look like?
And I'll probably ask a bunch of really
irritating nit picky questions because
that's how I am. But what does, what
does, what does, uh, when do you wake up?
What does the first 60 to 90 days, 60 to
90 minutes of your day look like? Yeah. So
I, I wish I had a really cool example of
that. Like, you know, Robin don't wake up,
I go on a Cryo Chamber,
Cryo Chamber. He's like,
if this elaborate ritual
of mind altering spiritual,
like jumping into a hot tank and a cold
tagging of mine involves my kids waking
me up at an ungodly hour
after I, you know, like we,
we work under the premise
of my wife and I and to me,
she gets us even more than I do because
she's got all the roles and all this
stuff and then she's mom. And
when you're the dad, it's,
it's, um, it's a big responsibility.
But the mom, like if anything happens,
if they wake up, they go
to her first. You know,
when the kids wake up in the middle
of the night, unless they're scared,
they might call dad if they're scared.
But usually it's mom because they
just more of the comforter, right?
So it's all those things. So
that's an even harder job. But,
um, you know, we, we train
late at night, we get home,
we tried to get home every night,
no matter what,
to spend a little bit of time with them
and put them down and, and, uh, you know,
read them a book,
whatever, get them in bed.
So Joe comes to my house around
10 o'clock. So by him, yeah.
So I get them done, you
know, we get them in bed, um,
change and then Joe's there and we start
training. And usually by, you know,
by the time you warm up takes me a
while to warm up at 10 o'clock at night,
train and do all this stuff. By the time
we get done, usually it's one o'clock,
you know, in that ballpark.
And then, you know,
you get in the bed after one o'clock,
they were up at like six at the latest,
you know, and they're in the room.
So there's no really cool ritual.
I wish I could say
jumping in a cryo chamber.
It's usually me stumbling
downstairs with them, um,
to try to make every
morning. My ritual is, um,
I, um, I'm also ironically out
of your book, Dave Palumbo.
Jumbo Palumbo. Yeah. Dave has, I've been
friends with them for years and he, um,
he's a big um,
uh,
ketogenic diet guy.
So he like works with my diet a lot
when I'm getting ready for wrestlemania
stuff. So Dave's kind of my diet guy uses
protein powder species protein is every
morning roll downstairs,
two scoops of whey protein,
a bunch of Starbucks coffee,
powdered Starbucks coffee, uh,
some Macadamia nut oil and I make
a shake and that's the start.
Like did you just got to
get the kick in the ass?
Starbucks macadamia nut oil.
What else was in there?
A two scoops of ice,
ally's protein and some
ice blend it all up.
It's a Starbucks,
a smoothie kind of concoction,
but very healthy and has enough caffeine
in there to at least make me realize
what's going on.
Get them ready for school.
My wife and I get them ready for school,
uh,
jump in the shower either, depending if
I'm getting ready for like Wrestlemania,
it's either throw sweats on,
cause I'm gonna bring them to school.
And then get a workout in because usually
I train twice a day when I'm getting
ready for Wrestlemania or something,
but a train and then off to work.
If I'm not getting ready for Wrestlemania,
it's shower, get ready, suit,
bring them to school, you know, we drive
them to their school, get them to school,
get them in their class to all this
stuff and then drive to the office,
start the day, get home at, you know,
seven 38 o'clock at night and repeat.
And this is all in Connecticut is
they're all in Connecticut. Yeah,
indeed. The HQ is, I want to say
stem that can get this wrong.
So Stanford is it separate is,
yeah. Yup. See it right from 95.
Right off the highway. Close to the UBS
building. Yeah. Yeah. Down the street.
Not Far. And he used to lift
and I used to work there,
the slip of the tongue and lived there.
It's probably appropriate.
He pretty much lived in the
office. What is your, uh,
what is your role currently at WWE in the,
in the executive capacity?
So I am the executive
vice president of talent,
live events and creative.
So if you look at the core
of what we do as a company,
like from the product itself,
raw, smackdown, all that.
And we're a lot more than that because
we have movies and music and like it's,
I say all the time, it's like saying
Marvel's a comic book company.
But that's the core of what we do.
I control those aspects.
So talent and that goes from,
we have a department tallow relations,
which is like their HR and they handle
everything that has to do with talent
from their travel to
and anything that has to do with them.
All the logistics of Wrestlemania Week,
you know, what talents are doing. There's
a thousand appearances for talent.
Literally in the week of Wrestlemania.
They have to handle all the logistics
of getting who were making sure nobody's
late and all of it. It's amazing. Um,
from to talent development,
which is the biggest probably thing
that's closest to my heart that I do,
which is where do we find talent?
What are we re recruit them from?
Where do we, where do we, um,
where do we recruit them from?
How do we train them?
We opened a performance center
in Orlando, Florida, um,
to a developmental territory
or a developmental, um,
system that I have called NXT that has
become kind of like an alternative brand,
um,
through to how do they then evolve and
get into the main roster of the WWE.
So basically what we did is kind of
created college football to get guys ready
for the NFL. And then, um,
the last part of what I do is creative,
which Vince is kind of the
ultimate filter of creative.
I'm more, um, while I,
I weigh in and a lot on that stuff and
the content that's going to go in the
network and all these things that I
weigh in on it from a creative concept.
But I'm also approving tee shirt designs
and banner designs and going through
all that stuff through all the different
departments and doing the approvals of
all that day to day process. Sounds like
quite a few hats. It's a lot of hats.
It's funny,
I used to marvel at Vince ability when
I first started coming in the office.
Um,
I,
I've had a working kind of behind the
scenes relationship with Vince since
probably I started in the WWE
and 95 since like early 96.
I just was always fascinated with a behind
the scenes of the business and how it
actually all came together as much
as I was doing it in the ring.
And he and I just kind
of clicked in that sense.
And we started working together
and I didn't meet staff,
his daughter until
quite a few years later.
And then we ended up having a
relationship and the whole thing.
But I had this working relationship
with Vince and as time went on and I got
more and more involved in that and
then kind of later in my career,
he kept always asking me like,
when are you going to stop messing around
in the ring and come do some real work
in the office? You know, you
need to be in the office.
I need to get you in the office. And, um,
I used to marvel at how many hats he wore
and how quickly he could change them.
You know,
he'd be talking about a foreign
tour and box office receipts or,
or you know, I'm a touring strategy
or marketing strategy for that.
And then two seconds
later he's looking at it,
a tee shirt design and approving colors
and that, and then that would go away.
And now he's, he's, you know, looking
at some new talent or he's like,
it's just was so many hats that he,
that he wore and it used to amaze me
how quickly he could change gears and I
find myself now having to
do that same thing. Um,
and it's,
it's really cool to see yourself growing
that way cause they used to think about
how does he keep that all straight.
And at first I couldn't keep it straight
and now you just, you learn it, you know,
you, you, you learned that
you adapt to that process.
I know we only have a few minutes left.
I feel like I can ask
you questions for hours.
So maybe we'll do a round two sometimes.
I love it. This is great. The,
I'd love to ask you some rapid
fire questions and,
uh,
I think we could do an entire
session just on productivity,
but just really quickly,
what is the,
the book that you have
gifted most to other people?
Okay.
Or any book you've gifted
a lot to other people. Um
hmm.
I don't know that I could answer that
question. I don't give books, watch.
Not a problem. Well, you, my friends
aren't big readers need to work on that.
We can come back to that. What, uh, what,
what band or song have you been
playing most on your iPhone or,
or, uh, in the car or otherwise?
It's lot lately it's been anything heavy.
Metallica, Motorhead, I'm, you know,
I'm in training mode for Wrestlemania,
so I,
I at 10 o'clock at night I need to put
something on the stereo that just makes
me,
gets me an ass kicking mode.
Uh,
if you could only do one or two physical
exercises for the rest of your life
movements,
what would they be?
Wow. Um, I think if, if,
if at this age,
if I could do like a free standing,
just bodyweight squats and pushups and,
um,
kind of bodyweight exercises would be
where I'd be at because I think you can
stay in phenomenal shape doing them and
you don't need a whole lot of space or
equipment.
I should dive at some point.
Introduce juicy to a buddy of mine named
Travis brewer who is a top competitor
on American Ninja Warrior and you
guys could, could trade work outs.
I think that'd be amazing.
Yeah. Easily. Yeah, I
bet you that's awesome
monster. I bet. What advice,
this will be the last question before I
ask you where people can find out more
about you online, but, uh, what advice
would you give your 20 year old self?
Don't take it all so serious, you
know, and, and, and be more open.
Um, it's, it's man,
when you're so focused on
making it and you're, um,
I always had fun in the business and
it was one of the things that I like.
I could, I, I can look
at it now and say like,
I didn't take everything so seriously
that it was detrimental to me,
but like there were times when it just,
something happened and just eat me up,
you know what I mean?
And I would be call. Yes.
Just couldn't take it because I was so
hungry to get to that next place. And,
um,
there you need to keep that,
that perspective of where
everything lays out. You know,
there's times when I,
uh,
when over the years when we've looked
at each other and my friends within the
business,
little group of guys,
and we'd always look at each other and
at a certain point in time you just laugh
and go like, hey, it's the phony fight
business. We're wrestling our underwear,
you know what I mean? Like, what
am I getting all worked up about?
You know what I mean?
And,
and
I think that that is the biggest thing
is just not taking it so seriously.
And then, and then being open
to stuff. You know, it's funny,
I mentioned that I listened to the Anthony
Robbins interview with you and I was
fascinated with it.
I met Anthony one time
and it was probably 2000.
I was just kinda like getting to a high
spot in my career and just happened to
be in a hotel. I look over next to
me, he's checking in next minute.
It's just a big giant
dude, you know? And uh,
but I recognize him from TV and he looked
over at me and said, how you doing?
I'm great. How are you? Good.
And then he got my keys and I went and
get in the elevator and he gets in the
elevator with me and he
looked at me and said, um,
forgive me. I don't know.
I don't know what you do,
but I clearly see people looking at you
and I clearly see your somebody and I
don't what, what do you do? And so I tell
them who I am and what I do. And I said,
I've seen you on TV, you
know, and um, you know,
one of those two second chance
meetings in an elevator, right?
And this really impressed me that I get
back a couple of weeks later and I get a
big box of like the cassette and his books
and all his stuff that he had written
me this handwritten letter and sent it,
didn't know how to get ahold of me,
send it to the WWE office,
whatever, two weeks,
a month later when I come back through
the office at some point in time in my
travels, they give it to me and
I'm like, wow, this is amazing.
I was too young and stupid and unopened
at the time to foster a relationship or
I listened to the tapes and I,
and I read the books and all that stuff.
And if I'd have thought about it,
maybe I would have reached back
out to say thank you and like, hey,
like this is really cool.
Can you know?
And he invited me to one of
his seminars and, and you know,
I was just at that time like I'm
doing good. Like I don't, you know,
it was close to it.
I wish I was more open to it.
I wish I could have had the bandwidth to
not be so absorbed in what I was doing
and my moments going for that I could
have said by this guy who could teach me
so much and Matt I should
call it. And just, you know,
to foster that relationship
cause he, he put the, put the,
put the handout and I was a guy who
know I don't need to him, you know, and,
and it's, um, and those
are things that I look,
there's other opportunities in
my life that I wish, Oh man,
I wish that was right in front of
me and I could have grabbed that,
but I was too narrow minded
to see it, you know? Well,
this has been fascinating
and you're fascinating guy.
I would love to do around two sometime,
but we're out of time.
I know your schedules
incredibly impressive to me. Ah,
where can people find more about you
online? Say Hi and so on. It's uh,
so uh, Twitter, uh, what,
what's my Twitter handle?
It's like a triple H.
I don't know.
I just know how to push the buttons
on it. I don't use search, easy peasy.
ww.com is for our, our, um,
for our company and our site
and all that. Um, you know,
I do stuff on Twitter and whether anybody
believes in or not, I actually do it.
It's not somebody else doing it. It's
me. So if it's terrible, it was me.
If it was really good, it
was me. Um, you know, uh,
if you want us to go back
and look at my career, um,
the WWE network is a great place to do it.
All the historical content is
on there. Um, you know, that's,
that's really me. But, uh,
you know, for me, I'm a,
I know you say,
I'm fascinated,
I'm fascinated by this process and
what you do and how you do it. Um,
and I'd love to do this again because I
think these kinds of things, it's funny,
a lot of things I said in here when
you ask me questions today, like I'm,
I feel like I gave you long
winded answers. I apologize
if I did, but like, so I'm,
I'm almost,
I'm almost explaining it to myself as you.
Well,
like I never thought about it that way,
so I'm kind of explaining it to you going
like, yeah, that's really cool. You know,
not long winded at all. They were,
uh, you're a great storyteller.
You're a great story creator, uh, an
incredible performer and I hope I am,
I'll never be as big as you,
but hopefully I will be as bulletproof as
you are when I'm 45 so until next time.
Thank you so much.
Thank you very much man.
This episode is brought to you
by listen headphones. Listen,
headphones are gorgeous,
made out of real exotic reclaimed wood,
but they are also doing good in the world.
He proceeds from each purchase help
someone to hear for the first time through
the Starkey hearing foundation.
I've been using listen headphones since
they came out partially because the
founders started the company after
reading the four hour workweek and now
they're available in Nordstrom
and all over the place.
They're super high quality and if you
want to see the headphones that I travel
with that I love with
any or an out of ear,
so kind of big Ole old school headphones,
then you can go to listen
to headphones.com forward
slash Tim that's lst n,
headphones.com forward slash Tim you
will also get a $50 that's right,
$50 discount. That's a big
weapon. Five zero folks,
so go to listen to headphones.com
forward slash Tim Ellis, t n,
headphones.com forward slash.
Tim,
this episode is brought
to you by 99 designs,
which is your one stop shop for
all things graphic design related.
They have thousands upon thousands
of designers around the world.
You put up what you want, whether that's
a business card, a tee shirt, a website,
an app thumbnail, whatever,
and they submit drafts,
mockups and designs that you can choose
from and you get an original design you
love or your money back.
I've used them for years,
including to grab cover
concepts for the four hour body,
which went on to become
number one New York Times,
and it really was a
springboard for everything.
So go to 99 designs.com forward slash
Tim and you can also get two things,
a $99 upgrade,
and just for the month of April,
just for you guys that you
can get an additional $30 off.
And that is a total savings of one 29 so
check out 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim. And until next time,
thank you for listening.